One of the most important concepts in programming, is the notion of a Data Type.
Which we also just call a type. You've been using types since your first
programming, so you already know a fair bit about types. We just haven't talked
about it explicitly until now. Understanding types more deeply, will make you a
better programmer, will help you understand more what's going on when your
programs run. It will also get you to the point where you can define your own
data types. And that will be useful for making our search engine kept more
modular, like we just talked about. So first thing I'm going to introduce some
terminology. Everything that you can reference in a Python program is an object.
What is the mean to be over the reference something. Well that means we can give
it a name. There are lots of ways to give things names. You could pass it as a
parameter, you could use it in an assignment. Anything that could be assigned to
a name is an object in Python. Every object has a type. We can think of types as
sets of values, and the type of an object tells us something about what we can
do with it. There is an easy way to explore types in Python, and that's to use
the built-in type operator. The type operator takes any object as its input, and
produces as it's output the type of the input object. Here's an example, so here
we're using type to find the type of the object which is the number 101. That's
an object. We can reference it. We can assign it to a variable. We could pass as
a parameter. So it must have a type and it has type int, which is short for
integer. What you might find a little more surprising. Is we can do the same
thing with functions, so we've defined the function double that takes one input
and returns x plus x. See if you can guess what the type of double is before I
evaluate this. It has type, and its type is function.